скажи чесно Як ти Якщо чесно то не
найкращий період в моєму житті спочатку
війни Я стала дуже тривожною і я не
довіряю людям я по 10 разів перевіряючи
закрили я двері дуже часто прокидаюсь
посеред ночі плачу кожен день сльози
якраз допомагають і цього не треба
боятися соромитися
Наступного разу Спробуй ще так
зхрести долоні зачепившись великими
пальцями так щоб вони нагадували
метелика приклади долоні до грудей та по
черзі ритмічно простукай себе по
ключицях через внутрішній вібрації ти
почуєш звуки ніби гучне серцебиття це
заспокоїть тебе
продовжуй цю вправу Доки не відчуєш що
дихання вирівнялося
доде цю техніку в свою аптечку
самодопомоги більше тут